- So Brendan, have you
seen "Stranger Things"
before you met on the movie?
- Yes, I have.
I saw the first season in its entirety.
I loved it 'cause I grew up
playing Dungeons and Dragons,
and the whole ensemble of
Stranger Things reminded me
of the crew that I used
to run around with.
And I lived in Seattle,
Washington in the late '70s.
So it was nostalgia for me.
I loved it.
And then after we finished "The Whale,"
a certain Sadie Sink went on to stare down
a really scary monster called Vecna.
And I know that's
because she had just come
from playing Charlie's daughter,
who has a great deal of finally focused
anger issues with her father.
So I think Sadie
definitely carried her work
from one project into the other,
'cause that Vecna guy ran with
his tail between his legs.
And I know why,
and it's not just because
her dad is a football coach,
and has a handshake like a stonemason.
I know, 'cause this hand still hurts.